[Music]
98 degrees is back 20 years after their
very first album the boys have a new
project in the works but ET online
sophie scholl AC wanted to know about
the newest thing and Nick Lachey's life
being on daddy duty again with little
son Phoenix congratulations on the the
baby you are the two older ones
adjusting to life with the little
brother my daughter especially just you
know dotes on him who loves him and hugs
him sometimes a little too tight do you
think you would ever do the reality
thing with your family no no definitely
not there's one thing to do it when
you're just a young person and you're in
this business but when you have a family
and you know your sole job is kind of
look out for your kid
nick has definitely come a long way from
his early days on newlyweds he posted
this side-by-side throwback photo that
shows his evolution in fact all the guys
of 98° have gone from boys to men drew
Lachey has two kids
Justin Jeffery ran for mayor of
Cincinnati but lost Jeff Timmons created
a Vegas show called men of the strip yes
three kids as well now are any of your
kids musically inclined do you see them
following in your footsteps at all
unfortunately yes yeah unfortunately
yeah I was I was hoping for medicine
maybe my daughter is now transitioning
to becoming a model right like so you
know trying to stand back as an
experienced person in the business and
watch her do her thing is tough it's
[Music]
now 20 years after their debut 98
degrees we'll release a new holiday
album called
let it snow they'll also start a new
tour November but they're leaving their
families at home having your whole
family on the road it's tough for them
it's tough for us is it distracting you
want to say your family is a distraction
but yes they're shortchanging the fans
or your shortchanging your families and
the guys 31 32 or 98 degrees at
Christmas a runs through December the
23rd